once everything was awesome
now everything is okay Lucy I brought
you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh did
I interrupt you brooding just now times
have changed you need to change with
them we have to be tough and
battle-ready
[Music]
hurry the door is slowly closing
oh hey it's Kane so cold
see that wasn't so bad nothing got in
this is all my fault
hang on your fronds planet we're going
to save
[Music]
you mind if I save your life not at all
who are you names Rex danger vet galaxy
defending archaeologist cowboy and
Raptor trainer I don't get it we'll help
me rescue my friends you don't want to
go anywhere near that sistar system it's
ruled by an alien coin only the toughest
you're gonna get out of there alive I'm
a queen whatever I would not be I'm
getting super evil Phibes the ARCA
change my form to something else if this
makes you uncomfortable hey guys they'll
go back don't worst was much more
palatable double dots on your face
[Music]
who are you I'm your worst nightmare Oh
me when I'm late to school and I forgot
my homework and my pants are made of
pudding
no I don't
[Music]